[Music]
if you follow me on the Twitter you know
that I'm not a big fan of award shows in
general but all the talk post Golden
Globes this week is about Oprah Winfrey
potentially running for president in
2020 mainstream media is in love with
the idea of Oprah for president and CNN
the New York Times Time magazine and a
slew of others have all already run
think pieces on her chances in just
three short years Hollywood of course is
also in love with the idea the
conscience of lefty Hollywood Jimmy
Kimmel has already said that he's on
board with Oprah 2020 and NBC even
tweeted from their official account at
NBC that Oprah is our next president
though they eventually deleted the tweet
make no doubt the elite class that was
dealt a swift blow by the election of
Trump in 2016
will quickly fall in line if Oprah
decides to make a run for 2020 Oprah has
an absolutely remarkable life story she
grew up in a milling house in extreme
poverty she survived absolutely horrific
physical and sexual abuse including
being raped by her own cousin when she
was only nine years old from these
unimaginably difficult beginnings Oprah
eventually made it to local news in
Chicago and then on to her syndicated
talk show which not only changed the TV
landscape but had a cultural relevance
unlike almost anything in the
pre-internet age every politician
pop-culture icon an ordinary person
doing something extraordinary seemed to
make it to Oprah's couch since she ended
the talk-show seven years ago Oprah's
had many professional ups and downs
continuing to navigate Hollywood
starting her own TV network own which
has in quite caught on doing plenty of
charity work and of course and perhaps
most importantly always making time to
eat bread with very excited strangers
around a fancy table in a forest as for
Oprah's politics I'm not sure anyone
other than Oprah herself has a full view
of them she was a big Obama supporter
during his first two campaigns and I
have no doubt that she falls on the
Democrat progressive side of things how
she Falls specifically on every issue
I'm not totally sure but we seem to be
veering towards a cliff where the issues
will have almost nothing to do
who gets elected the cult of personality
we're building around politicians and
what that means for the health of our
society in the long term is quickly
becoming a massive problem that's hidden
in plain sight
I'm pretty sure I don't have to say much
on the cult of personality that is
Donald Trump
make no mistake whether you love or hate
Donald Trump we elected a reality TV
star a man created by and now hated by
the mainstream media Trump's rise used
all the tools of the media against
itself and that's why right now the
media is endlessly looking to destroy
him they want their narrative and
control back notice the shift in TV
coverage and articles about Trump in the
last two weeks or so it's shifted from
endless Russia stories to Trump's mental
health in most cases the people writing
these stories are the same people who
said that stories about Hillary's health
were conspiracy theories even after she
collapsed and was dragged into an SUV by
security guards that autumn day in New
York City so what we have right now is a
cult of personality Trump versus the
cult of the media this has made a lot of
people a lot of money as long as they
keep churning out articles and think
pieces true or not people do get paid to
this end Trump is their perfect foil he
has no shortage of tweets to send out
and people to mock so we've got a match
made in hell playing right in front of
all of our eyes now back to Oprah for a
moment
Oprah is basically the exact reverse of
Trump even at the identity politics
level she is a black woman and he is a
white man she grew up poor he grew up
rich but more importantly than these she
says all of the right things she talks
about love and spirituality and is loved
by the Hollywood and media class as one
of their own Trump on the other hand is
their perfect enemy as if they had
written the script themselves alas Trump
was one of their own until he became too
powerful and now he is enemy number one
because they've lost control of the
narrative their hope is that they can
win some of that narrative back with
another celebrity who will play by their
rules but I think that this is
short-sighted at best and disastrous at
worst just imagine what kind of insane
polarizing sensationalized lunacy the
potential matchup of Trump verse
Oprah will lead to as we head into 2020
it'll be great for clicks and ratings
but it'll be terrible for ideas and
debate you thought Hillary verse Trump
was polarizing just wait until Trump and
Oprah battle it out in the Thunderdome
on prime-time television sadly it
doesn't look like we'll ever turn back
to being governed as our founders
intended with a limited federal
government and strong states that
empower people to control their lives at
the local level while Trump has done
some good work in limiting the power of
the federal government he's obviously
happy to govern by executive action as
Congress seeds more and more of their
duties to the executive branch instead
of the legislative branch where laws are
supposed to be written his Justice
Department too is happy to step on the
Tenth Amendment and allow the federal
government to trample on states rights
just look at Attorney General Jeff
Sessions decision to allow the feds to
crack down on state's ability to
legalize marijuana so to sum up we'll
have a president that will most likely
be a celebrity whether it's Trump or
Oprah or Mark Cuban or the rock along
with an executive branch that'll
continue growing and growing in power
this cult of personality will
continually put people into office not
on what they believe and whether they
understand or even care about how
government is supposed to work but
rather by what they make us feel and how
they can manipulate us into thinking
exactly as they do that feeling coupled
with the growing power of the office of
the presidency is a recipe for the
authoritarian control we all should be
wary of the only way to fight this tide
of celebrity induced idiocracy is to get
involved now before it's too late either
that or get ready to bow to supreme
leader Justin Bieber in 2024
[Music]
joining me today is a New York Times
bestselling author a presidential fellow
at Chapman University the founder of
skeptic magazine and now a four-time
Rubin report guest Michael Shermer
welcome back to write my fourth time
here at times that's a record or without
it you are close you are you're
definitely in the top two or three oh
cool all right
depending on how this goes do I get a
pay bump yet no but there's plenty of
booze okay that's right yeah that's
right
so all right there's a ton I want to
talk to you about you've got a new book
coming out I was saying to you right
before you started you're the only guest
that has two books all right moral or
skeptic okay good well you you are doing
well we can bump the skeptic and put
heavens on earth there because I hate to
be the lifeboat guy that kicks the other
person hosta out of the lifeboat we will
swap those two I thought a fun way
though to start this conversation with
you would be to tell a little story that
happened to us both when we spoke at
University of Arizona about two or three
months ago we were we were speaking
there with who were with that night we
were with Steve Simpson yes from the ein
Rand Institute we're just gonna talk on
free speech about an hour talk half hour
or so Q&A and in the middle I jokingly
said to the audience by a show of hands
are there any Nazis here it's very edge
to our surprise someone raised their
hand or a woman raised her hand and said
that she was a Nazi and she started to
ask a question I said you know what hang
tight respect to our free speech we're
gonna do our thing but then when we open
this up to the Q&A we're gonna throw the
first question to you so this person
then proceeded to ask a question can you
paraphrase what the question was
basically oh well it was something about
she had encountered me before it's some
public event about the Holocaust story
and you know some details about the gas
chambers and you know one of these kind
of technical arguments that they come up
with that are supposed to stump
Holocaust historians but that I've
refuted before and then she wanted to
revisit that so basically it
was she was a Holocaust denier and the
beauty of what happened why I wanted to
start this conversation with this
antidote was she asked you this question
about the doors at Auschwitz and why
they didn't lock and all of this I'm
sorry was bad that's right the doors of
madhouse and yeah that's right yeah
right yeah yeah and basically you gave
her a great answer of why the doors in
lock and they didn't want to scare
people with doors that lock at an
obviously very scary place and all this
stuff and it was it was a really nice
moment for free speech I thought she
actually respected our free speech we
then allowed her to have the question
you then answered her question now it
was pretty obvious to me that you didn't
change her mind at the end and that's oh
that's the first question I'm gonna ask
when you when you come by as someone
that debunks conspiracy theories all the
time and created skeptic magazine when
you come across these people that are so
sort of tightly held to their conspiracy
theories or the ideas that they can't
prove but they just believe them
right how often can you actually break
through you can actually I get letters
all the time I don't have it like a data
set from 25 years with 10,000 subjects
or anything like that but I get a ton of
letters just from people saying you know
I used to believe X and now I believe
why I changed my mind after reading your
book or you and Dawkins or Paris or
hitch and so you know whatever this sort
of a list of people that we know and so
I do think this idea that you can't talk
somebody out of something that they
didn't you know you can't reason
somebody out of a belief they didn't
reason their way into I think it's not
true even though probably they didn't
reason their way into the art the belief
in the first place once you have the
belief in place then you find reasons to
believe it and smart people are really
good at this
educated will verse people can pile up
the arguments and data in favor of their
belief and disconfirm ignore the
disconfirming evidence you know the
confirmation bias so but you can do that
you can and so and now they're Studies
on on this by cognitive psychologists
like you know if you're teaching
critical thinking and and the students
believe this how do you get them from
there to there
whatever it is ESP or UFOs conspiracies
ER or some political economic idea so
you can do this
not standing at the blackboard yammering
away but by getting them to debate and
engage with each other like okay so
you're pro-choice okay you're now gonna
argue the pro-life position against this
person here who's going to take the
opposite position what they believe and
that sort of forces them to think well
okay what are the arguments in favor of
this now I got a make up and then that's
forces them to listen to the other
person and think about that and then
they can they really have a sense of
what's the best arguments because they
have to make them so really it's just
engaging in a process it's like you're
not gonna learn to play the violin by
reading a book about violins or
listening to a lecture about how the
violin works you got to just do it in
your years of doing this have you
learned anything about the mind of the
type of people that are prone to
conspiracy theories is there like a
certain set of ideas that they more
broadly subscribe to before it gets to
whatever the yeah yeah so there's kind
of a global cognitive style that
everything happens for a reason
now for religious people this is you
know Jesus or God is sort of directing
things everything from the parking spot
you got to the college you went into
your spouse that you met and and so
forth the little to the big questions
for the conspiracists it's the
government it's a little g-god
government that's you know pulling the
strings and even if it's you know if the
Illuminati or the one-world or whoever
the Rockefellers the Rothschilds it's
still kind of a government type that
there's somebody up there pulling the
strings so that everything that happens
for a reason so and we know that from
surveys that people that tick the box
that that you know JFK was assassinated
by a conspiracy are also more likely to
take the box that Princess Diana was
murdered you know Elvis is still alive
you know that you know the aliens are
being hidden in area 51 you know so they
they go down the path they tend to
accept more and more ideas now we might
call that you know a gullibility
tendency or something like that but
there's something beneath that which is
everything has a reason for why it
happens and that they downplay the role
of chance and randomness so it's
interesting how you relate that to the
religious mind because there's a desire
really to
and what's happening and yet right the
desire I think you would argue that you
then have to take a lot of things that
aren't true for fat like there's sort of
no ending to it right that's right they
never get to the end of the conspiracy
theory and then it's exposed really it
just sort of takes you further and oh
that's like an x-files series obviously
one it's episode leads to the next and
they keep pulling the strings the thread
and that keeps unraveling forever so
it's really a self-fulfilling prophecy
in a way right if you can never be
proven wrong because that's right yes
yes yeah so I was just debating just
online for the UFO people about this new
story about the Pentagon had this
program to study UFOs
now they call them unidentified aerial
phenomenon UAP sounds more technical
right and that is goofy but but of
course you know they're interested in an
unidentified aerial something or other
because it could be the Russians or the
Chinese or who knows what you know so
it's perfectly reasonable to also then
understand that well the government's
that you know they lied to us yeah no
kidding governments do lie to their
citizens right you know but but a good
counter to this is you know the the
WikiLeaks you know here here we have you
know millions of documents that were
secret that we weren't supposed to see
and now we see them and there's nothing
in there about 9/11 was an inside job
the alien bodies are being held at area
51 the UFO was engineering technology
was back engineered and this is how we
got the Space Shuttle nothing nothing
like that so this is a good example that
they've released yes that's right yeah
yeah well but presumably you know the
WikiLeaks guys weren't you know hiding
the good stuff and and releasing only
because they've released you know
millions of documents so this is an
example of the absence of evidence is is
evidence of absence in terms of that
argument usually that doesn't that
doesn't hold water but in this case I
think it does so where are you just sort
of personally are you feeling good about
the state of skepticism at the moment or
are you feeling that fake news and the
authoritarian control on both sides
these days just that everything so up in
the air
you know feel good about what it is that
you do and what the things that seems
like we're not supposed to and they are
of Trump and all this stuff but really
things just keep grinding along and in a
positive fashion the counter to the fake
news and alternative facts are all the
new fact-checking sites like politifact
and Snopes has gotten huge now and that
skeptic we're just we're gonna launch a
fact-checking site because this is the
kind of thing we should be doing and and
there's I don't know there's half a
dozen of those sites that every
political speech now given is followed
by really clickbait tweets on here are
the 27 facts that are wrong in this
speech Oh might want to see what they
are yeah so really that's the market
counter to that not censorship or we
need laws about fake news no we just
need people back Jackie and then when
having problems with even that that
people go to those sites and then even
if you fact check it they still don't
believe the facts that they don't like
like we've really yeah that for the
ground sort may be but on the other hand
the moment like post modernists and or
even like behavioral economists say that
you know we're incapable of reason yeah
what are your arguments and reasons for
that statement then the moment they open
their mouth they've refuted them so
right because we still use arguments and
reason even if you're even if your
arguments or your data or fake or you
know questionable you're still trying to
make a good argument so that
enlightenment program of we use science
science and reason to make political
progress is still in place yeah well
that concept I think is really
interesting because you have all these
people right now who think either you
know Armageddon is coming tomorrow or
everything everything's never been worse
I think we hear that over here we've
never hated each other more bah-bah-bah
and I'm pretty sure it was the first
time I had you on the show and we were
talking about the moral arc which is
right over there that you were saying
that the arc of progress has bent so
that actually things are better but but
it seems like we don't really stop and
smell the roses
that seems like a group rotten to me at
the moment and if and when something
does get exposed as you know here's this
evil in society that now we're alerting
to like the me to movement and and some
of the other ones that have
in the last year or so that just exposes
how far we've come and how sensitized
our moral compass is to things that are
really bad and that we're going to jump
on it and not allow this anymore so that
if anything gets us and like with the
stuff we've talked about with the
student protests you know complaining
about Halloween costumes okay this is
actually a sign of progress I mean no
one worried about Halloween costumes in
1950 okay the moral Crusaders like
Martin Luther King weren't you know oh
what are the Halloween costumes good
they're worried about you know the KKK
costumes that are real okay so that's
how far we've come when it can be so
finely tuned that we're gonna pick these
little knits over here does that also
show you why the level of hysteria maybe
is ramped up so much because the less
stuff there is to really fight about
yeah there isn't some stuff but the less
stuff that really we don't this isn't
the 1950s KKK it's and run it maybe a
couple losers with a truck that it
couldn't but that's why the people that
scream don't have to scream louder
because they sort of need it you know I
think so yeah yeah and I you know the
fact is they say students at colleges
like at Evergreen they have their moral
modules ramped up to 11 like any of us
do on a cause we believe in it's just
that from a bigger picture when you look
at well what are you all ramped up about
what why is your moral module dialed to
11 over this silly little thing here
well they don't know what it used to be
like you know half a century ago they
weren't even alive so they have the
issues they're concerned about but they
have the same moral modules everybody
else has so what do you make of the
state of education in general everything
we talk about everything you've written
all these books about yeah it's based in
educating some people first yes yes it's
still the most important thing we can do
I don't think higher education is gonna
disappear I don't think brick-and-mortar
universities are going to disappear I
think they'll just be more options
online options say you know all these
MOOC courses and and you know teaching
company courses and audiobooks and
podcasts and so on these are just more
avenues for dispersing information and
ideas and discussing them I think that's
just going to continue and along with
standard educational things now again I
mentioned earlier about you know the the
professor standing at the blackboard
yammering away for hours well
students are on there now they're just
on social media not even listening okay
so that's what has to change I think
professors teachers need to get more
engaged I'm a professor I know this is
harder to do it's easy once you've got
the lectures written you got the
PowerPoint set up you just walk in boom
and off you're off and running fifty
minutes later you're done and you're off
having your coffee okay
it takes more preparation to think about
okay I got how am I gonna get these
students to engage in this subject in a
way that they'll actually get something
out of it and that takes more work so I
think you gave me an example already but
tell me a little bit about how you
prepare so you're teaching skepticism
101 yeah happen from everything I know
about Chapman who's the the Dean that
Danielle East Roopa yeah is the
president is the president yeah so I
heard him speak a couple months ago in
Dallas at an event and it was an
absolutely wonderful defense of free
speech yes yes of values of what
academia is supposed to be that's right
and I wanted to say hi to map in
attention that you've been on my show a
couple of times but so it seems like you
guys are doing something right over
there is that fair they are yes
absolutely they they are not a
politically left or right University
they're just open to ideas the fact that
they have the you know statues of the
Civil Rights champions like Martin
Luther King but also economic freedom
champions like Hayek and and von Mises
you know they're on campus you know
others might think oh this is a right
wing you know libertarian nut job can't
no actually I had my students one
semester for their research project new
try to sample the faculty on their
political beliefs now I talked to
Danielle about this and he and the
administration are not allowed to do
this they can't ask professors what
their political persuasions are but the
students can just you know just sort of
email take my little survey and it was
pretty centrist there was still you know
a slight leaning toward the left you
know I don't know where you'd put it on
the scale but left leaning and but but
by Berkeley or evergreen standards this
would be right wing all right you know
nutjob campus right but really they're
just kind of centrist and I actually
think there's probably a little bit of a
bias that you and I have been subject to
in the sense that we
focus on the evergreens and in the
Middlebury incidences because they do
stand out and we forget all that you
know so Evergreen has like 4,000
students right there was maybe 200
involved in the whole Bret Weinstein
thing all right what were the other
3,800 doing they were probably holed up
in their dorm rooms they don't want to
get involved they're not interested they
just want to study you know I but I
think but my fear with them is that it's
a little bit of intellectual
hostage-taking that yes you might be
right the the large bulk of them may not
care about this or may think it's silly
or whatever but I think there's a huge
percentage I don't know what the
percentage is that are just afraid to
speak yes every time I speak to colleges
that's what they asked me in the Q&A s
what can i I don't want to get kicked
out of college right that my fraternity
had my professor flunk me all that that
there is this feeling of that I don't
know that anyways I've never seen
numbers on that that would be a good
question hard to get the data
it's self-report data and people it's
hard to get people to be honest about
that sort of thing but I'm let's say
it's 50/50 half don't care have to care
and keeping their mouth shut
every semester I ask my students how
many of you self-censor because you're
afraid to say something like the
politically correct language or whatever
and you know the most of them raised
their hand yes they do some self sensory
so for sure that that happens but I was
encouraged by the Reed College incident
where you know the humanities 101 was
protested its to white male you know
Shakespeare and Greeks and Romans and
then finally some black students you
know said get out I want to get my
education I'm paying $50,000 a year yeah
and it's like good alright so fighting
back what do you think it makes a the
audacity of a 18 year old to get up I
mean I watch that video people can find
it on YouTube I think the class was
about Greek the history of Greeks who
have given us over but every balance
that logic and reason that we have right
now yeah and talking about how it's
white supremacists and all the usual
nonsense but to me it was like those
kids who get up and do this it's not
like the level of self-importance marais
so off the charts that you dare it's not
even what you're doing to yourself it's
what you're doing to all of these other
brand paid to go to school and you think
you're wiser right the professors and
administrators and all that really well
we do have research on this from social
psychology for decades now that you only
need a few Confederate
a few yeah Confederates people that will
just go along with you now the
competitors not the right where that's
what experimenters put somebody in there
but but affiliate somebody that will
stand with you like in the Milgram
experiments if there's somebody else in
the room with you that says wait a
minute I don't think we should be
shocking this guy then the actual
subject will not go this far on the
shock things in the same thing with the
line lengths Solomon Asch is famous one
you know here's three lines you know
here's one line and pick the one that
matches it and everybody in the room
says it's this one over here it clearly
doesn't Majan most of the subject go
along with the group but if you have one
other in the room that picks the right
link line then almost everybody does
pick the right so you only need one or
two affiliate just somebody to stand
with you and it's just sort of common
knowledge that Oh like the emperor has
no clothes if somebody would just say it
right maybe two or three people would
say it that everybody else who already
knows what the truth is that then they
have the courage to say it if there's
not punishment for it so mystic regimes
in communist regimes have always kept a
check on that by punishing dissenters
which is why free speech is so important
but but also whistle blow we have to
protect whistleblowers get to protect
protect and in a way you know like with
virtue signaling we need to signal to
the people that are willing to stand up
you get moral points for what you just
did yeah well I think that's why I've
tried to be part of this conversation at
some level but also talk to all of these
people so when this happened with Brett
Weinstein or Laura Kipnis or Lindsey
Shepherd or Jordan Peterson etc etc I
offered them that chair because I want
people to certainly yes that's right as
Douglas Murray said to me when I asked
him you know people think you're so
brave you talk about all of this stuff
and the crumbling of the West yes yeah
and I said well what makes you so brave
and he said well you know something to
the effect of in his great British
accent you know the water the water
isn't so cold when you actually get in
and I think that's what it is that we're
gonna put a sort of imagine that if you
start saying what you think horrible
things are gonna happen but in most
cases I think they don't yeah so I mean
like the Lindsey Shepherd you got yes
she you know she's a complete nobody
who's ever heard of her boomed now she's
like this sensational star of freedom
and liberty
and free speech and is anything with
Jordan Peterson I know he has a lot of
enemies but boy he's got a lot of
followers my god yeah it's just huge and
so I think there's more people on that
side they they haven't been as loud and
the other side has a bigger voice
because you know negativity always
Trump's positivity you know it's it's
like be it's like I talked about in the
book you know but people hate to lose
more than they like to win you know it's
a it's a behavioral economics loss
aversion yeah loss is hurt twice as much
as gains feel good you know our brains
are tuned to negative things for very
good reasons that you know evolution and
the life before the modern world was a
dangerous place there's a lot of things
that could take you out and very few
things that make life better so it's
better to focus on the negative things
that can take you out and then just sort
of accept that the good days as they
come but you don't have to pay that much
attention to it so the you know the
negative tweets in social media they
always stand out which is why you just
kid don't read um yeah it's are not -
but so is this sort of a theory behind I
guess every local news broadcast in the
history of the world right it's just you
know fire here murder here is that's
their test to do that that's okay yeah
you know we just have to remind
ourselves that is not representative of
the way life is how can we change our
brains to think differently then because
I think a lot of people want that right
now I think there's there's an
exhaustion with the our age I think
there's an exhaustion with hating each
other and all that you know that's why
you know what we're doing and this
broader group of people is yes I think
that's why it's working we just have to
make our voices louder and just remind
people you know there are lots of
sources to go to to show how good luck
just reading one in your green room of a
site that had the 99 best things that
happened in 2017 that made it the best
year in the history of humanity there's
like a long title like the 99 oh my god
I started scanning that is like oh yeah
I forgot about that last February this
really cool thing happen Boombah Boombah
boom and even I am a super optimist and
I pay attention to stuff I didn't know
half the things on his list like oh yeah
Wow
okay so here we go yeah and people like
you and Pinker you know and that really
who you know track the the which that
site our world and data human progress
thought
org I think or calm human progress you
know and they just this is all they do
is track this stuff you know poverty
will be extinguished by 2030 maybe
sooner you know the Gates Foundation
posts all this stuff the work they're
doing to eradicate disease in Africa you
know specific target which is why you
know I I rail against utopia in this
book but instead of aiming for like in a
thousand years gonna have a perfect
world forget that just try to eradicate
this particular disease in the next ten
years in that country right there that's
it yeah we're all right we're gonna dive
deep into this book but let's just do a
little bit more before then you said
you're an optimist we're how does that
how does a skeptic become an optimist
well this may just be temperament I'm
just sort of a happy fellow and I I just
tend to see the world fairly
optimistically I'm not sure why that
could just be you know the behavior
genetic stuff half of our temperament is
heritable it's got it from my parents so
and I do tend to you know Steve Jobs had
that reality distortion field he talked
about you know no Steve we can't program
this in by next month yes we can and you
will
you know these are not the drones you're
like I will get it programmed but yes I
have a little bit of that not not to
that extent that can be a little
dangerous you know like I'm going to
ignore the cancer and just you know no
there's some things you shouldn't ignore
but for the most part when I get up you
know it's like like everybody else is
like what am I going to do today and I
don't feel that motivated and then I
just sort of get going and then and I
tend to perceive things that could be
negative in a positive way sometimes I
have to sort of force myself I do follow
people on Twitter for example that are
pretty positive like Pinker or like
jackal will Nick you know he's he's you
know he tweets every morning his workout
I've started you see his watch for 30 ma
a.m. yeah yeah alright so then I think
okay you know what I can do this come on
and I learned tended to start reality a
little bit we do know from research on
entrepreneurs and other people that it's
good to be a little on the optimistic
side versus pessimistic side now you
don't want to have the over optimism
bias see the entrepreneurs I think I can
succeed no matter what and they just
keep plowing money into a failed
business you know that's that's not good
and of course we only hear about the
Steve Jobs of the world you know the
the model drop out of college I move
back to your parents house and start a
startup in the garage and you'll be a
billionaire right I just leave there's a
lot of people that did that the 70s and
no one writes biographies of them
because they went out of business
parents with old yeah so you know
there's too much of that but but too
much too much negativity makes you feel
so it's called learned helplessness like
there's nothing I could do I mean you
know we got Trump and we got the economy
in North Korea
Serio it's just it's all lost what's the
point I can't do anything I'm just one
person and then you just kind of sink
you know like there's nothing to do
that's not good either so as an optimist
and a skeptic regardless of how much of
this was just built in in your DNA how
much do you think is sort of the right
amount of news to take you know it's all
sometimes people say well Dave why don't
you do a daily show right we could do
this five days a week yeah am i feeling
generally beyond that I don't even know
that the economic economic part makes
sense to us is that I think there's a
limit to how much people should be
talking about I do to politics all the
time then you could have a Twitter feed
screen right here and sit here 24/7 it
would never end it really sounds like my
words now look what happened now yeah
yeah I think that's too much I'll uh I
do consider I'm a consumer of content I
do tend to prefer the kind of long-form
essays you know the old New Yorker
Atlantic styles and I still read those
but now there's a lot of good sites like
this a on a eo-n site quill let in Louis
Roulet in Australia they have these
three three to five thousand word essays
they're great that's the kind of content
I like I do sometimes slip over and do
just the daily stuff and I find if I
don't stop you know I'm just I'm sliding
down and my optimism is like oh god what
can I do it's just rumors stop just get
off close it close laptop you're pretty
good about it though because I don't see
you fighting with that many people
online although every now and again I've
seen you get into something with another
academic somewhere and I've opened the
door and I can't even remember the
woman's name it's not even that
important unless you want to
specifically talk about it but you got
into something with some woman about
post-modernism and I said hey let's
let's talk about
you know and then she's really said
saying that it's basically that you're a
sexist and I'm impartial and the usual
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well you know
I'm 63 right so I'm not you know super
engaged because I'm slightly older
although I did get into the social media
enough to like I could see this is kind
of where the the conversation is
shifting you know from books and you
know public lectures to online content
and I like it but I'm not obsessed with
about it you know people that are maybe
in their 20s and that maybe they just
can't you hear about this you know
addicted to social media addicted to
your phone is like really but I can see
I could see how it happens you get the
little dopamine hit every time you you
know you scroll through and you see your
name on there and do you think that
amount of information at our fingertips
also feeds into why people believe in
conspiracy theories well it's just more
available yeah yeah for sure
yeah yeah so like maybe 20 years ago 25
years ago it would have been harder for
the 9/11 truthers to get it told
whatever the equivalent of that would
have been the Watergate inside job or
whatever because they didn't have a
platform that everyone's a publisher now
and you can just have your own web page
it looks like a magazine or whatever and
that they would have been harder to find
they're available and you could find
stuff but you know it's more like ersatz
publishing or you put pamphlets in a
leaflets on car windshields or you you
know you go to lectures and say stuff
now it's just it's too easily available
but on the other hand so are the counter
pages that can debunk them yeah that
part's good so I want to talk a little
bit about your politics specifically
because you took the political compass
test a couple months ago well yeah and
you posted your results online and then
I took it maybe a day or two after we
were pretty damn close yeah yeah all
right that's good cuz I like same to me
yeah okay and it basically we both came
out sort of center-right yeah so as you
know I've tried for a long time to
reform the left and I think this has led
left me as a liberal to be right and the
odd ways that things change over time
what do you even consider yourself at
this point I know you kind of said you
were a libertarian the first time I had
yes yes well well I buy your t-shirt
yeah
classical liberal classical liberal I
think maybe is the right phrase now the
libertarian label has gotten a lot of
baggage over the years it's collected a
lot of stuff from people on the fringes
you know oh so you don't believe in any
government no no no no and that's not
what I believe or or you know you're
like Rand Paul or Ron Paul or your EIN
Rand or you know they pluck these people
out and it's a cognitive shortcut a
heuristic in which I don't have to
actually talk to you about anything I
already know what you think so I don't
like that you know it's like well you
know okay don't ask me my what my
political affiliation is ask me my
position on abortion gun control death
penalty and so on and I'll tell you what
I think why I think it and then we can
go from there yeah you know but of
course who has time to do all that you
know so we like the labels yeah but
let's do one of those because I had been
Shapiro on my song yeah and you know we
had a really I think interesting honest
sort of painful at some level discussion
about abortion it's one of the most you
know you know difficult topics to talk
about we never in mainstream media see
it discussed honestly really that I see
anyway and basically my argument was
that I'm pro-choice but at basically
twenty weeks where they've been proven
that at that point the fetus can feel
pain yeah then at that point I think you
probably could say all right you can't
have an abortion but then that leads to
all sorts of other questions which is
you know they'd have to have a
responsibility which I don't like that
right anyway Ben is Benny's pro-life you
you sent me a very brief email with your
thoughts on this so yeah well I just
yeah I was watching it live which is it
is great and so I just sent that it was
an article about from a on actually
about the history of infanticide in our
species you know a lot but lots of
species do this and evolutionary
biologists have studied this for a
century why would in a Darwinian model
why would a parent kill an offspring
that's their DNA well it depends on the
calculation of resources available for
how many you can bring to reproductive
age that is our s reproductive success
of a species depends is defined by how
much of your genes get into the future
genome of the species going forward so
if you are
selected species you have like salmon
you have you know ten million eggs and
you know a hundred of them make it to
the top of the stream and and they're
the ones that succeed if you're a
elephant or a primate you have two or
three and you put all of your resources
into those and so these are different
reproductive strategies and in our
species what's happened over all the way
up until really well into the 20th
century until the introduction of birth
control women just kill their babies
after they were born and it sounds cruel
but you know it's just a basic triage
decision to make
I can't feed anymore kids this you know
when you live in really anytime before
the 20th century it was pretty
impoverished compared to today's
standards which is what we're used to
you just can't have that many kids
they're just gonna starve to death or
whatever and you know in lots of
societies anthropologist tell us you
know like these Inuits you know they
just leave the kid out there and if he
survives then for two days then we'll
bring him in and make them a part of our
family if not out you know Spartans did
the salaat societies did not because
they were immoral
you know they've presumably they feel
grief about it but they just can't do it
so one argument among men well is there
a moral argument there though is it not
that they're not immoral you know well
there's something yeah this is a hard
question okay so I'm making the argument
that practically speaking if you
restrict women's ability to control
their family size they're gonna do it
anyway say okay you can't have an
abortion well just we're just gonna get
more trash camp babies more babies the
infant's left in the park now that is
not that's not a moral argument Ben
would say something like oh so you're
saying murder is fine before or after
birth no no I'm just telling you
historically this is what happens now
the ideal solution would be more
prosperity for women more control over
their reproductive choices more control
over their family size and so on access
to abortion if you need it but we do
know from studies that abortion rates go
down when women have you know more
political power or economic freedom and
especially access to birth control
technologies and so religion is
traditionally restricted those and that
leads to more abortions or in other
cases more infanticide so that's one
angle I come at it
not it's really more of a practical
historical angle than a that a purely
moral one right so that you really just
give me the realist
yes it's a realist yeah now morally okay
so with these difficult questions we
have competing moral dilemmas or
competing moral positions and and and
they're going to conflict with one
another so you have the rights of the
fetus the rights of the woman okay so
there's not one right answer so if you
say well you should be a utilitarian or
you should be a Content you know this
will tell you what you should do but but
those aren't necessarily absolutely
right across the board no one could be a
pure utilitarian or a pure Con Thien or
Aristotelian virtue ethics none of them
work across the board you can always
find some exception which is why we
still have these elaborate ethical
debates because it's not solvable you
know so you have the the you know the
state should have some say over whether
citizens murder each other or not and
they should be able to implement
punishments that are appropriate so
death penalty yeah but there's all these
other sites so you have these
conflicting so how do we resolve it
debate votes laws that get changed
legislation that changes and I it's hard
because there's not one clearly right
answer so I suspect that you thought my
argument was actually pretty decent then
right like it's been yeah absolutely of
course hundred percent I'm a pro-choice
I forget exactly the way you said it
barely just but that basically at twenty
weeks
that's because then it gets your right
it gets caught in now okay well if you
believe it's a life it's a life at
eighteen weeks and at twenty weeks so
where are we you know drawing these
lines all the time you have to draw the
line somewhere frozen embryos you know
as millions of them now yeah why are
they not life on bends you know we have
it's at the moment there's fertilization
that's a life okay that's true that's
it's well it's a potential human life
now there's the question of personhood
slightly different because a person has
legal rights under the Constitution of
the particular country and it's a
slightly different question than a
biological question but either way once
by Ben's argument once the fertilization
that happens that's a human life okay
yeah it's a potential human life so
killing the embryos
also wrong I don't know what he'd say
about that actually haven't heard his
position but I'd say it's a continuum
and the problem the difference between
the law and science is that science
deals in Continuum's in gray areas and
shades and nuance the law by definition
has to just say okay this is the law we
draw the line you know on this day of
this month that's it
no no abortions after that are legal and
I'm okay with that it's you know life is
messy we have to draw the line somewhere
yeah all right so one more thing before
we get to the book so I think one of the
best things that I did or that I was
part of last year was the debate that we
had here with you and Dennis pray about
God in morality right and obviously you
took the position that you do not need
God or a higher power
yeah moral Dennis took the opposite
position so two questions on this so
first when I left when we finish that I
sort of my my brain basically and most
of my being basically agrees with your
argument that I don't think my morality
purely comes from believing in God or
that most people's you know that you can
figure out a way to be moral the
interesting part of the conversation
came down to this micro verse macro
argument where basically Dennis was
saying to you well well you Michael on
the micro level you as an individual can
be very moral and I have no doubt that
you're a very moral person I'm basically
paraphrasing him but that at a societal
level yeah somehow the the man-made
morals that you prescribe to can't tie a
society together in the long term so
that we need these judeo-christian
values which then allow the
enlightenment to happen to then have
right moral or a society
I suspect you don't agree with that we
got into it a little bit but I just
wanted to kick it to you without someone
else yes well hitch still dealt with
this in his book God is not great and he
even cites Prager he said I was on
Prager show once and he guessed this
question you know of course you
personally could be moral but you know
as a society wouldn't you rather walk
down the street at 3:00 in the morning
in a dark alley in a society that was
you know more religious than less
religious and hitch promptly rattle off
cities he had walked around at 3:00 in
the morning after drinking
that he did they were very religious he
was not at all feeling comfortable or
safe yeah and any atom by name in the
you know a year and so on it's like yes
okay that's that's right yeah you know
Minh history I mean most judeo-christian
countries centuries ago we're not safe
places where you could be burned as a
heretic if you have the wrong beliefs
about the king or whatever it doesn't
matter what your religious beliefs are
these were your fellow Christians
killing you went all the way up to World
War one
you know Christian Germans killing
French Christians did I say that right
yes anyway so the correct order yeah so
now but but even so that that argument
is really more of a pragmatic kind of
utilitarian argument that whether or not
there's a God or religion is true or not
believing in it this is what Dan Dennett
calls belief in belief you know I don't
believe but I think people need to
believe there are some people that make
that a lot of atheist make that argument
hmm
it's sort of a condescending way of
looking at your fellow citizens you know
right I don't need it I can be moral but
these morons know they gotta have the
little policeman in the head or they
gonna kill each other and in a way the
founding fathers sort of Jefferson these
people talked about that you know more
in a deistic way and if we're gonna have
a kind of self organized self policing
society we can't get the state out there
to those western states which was like
Ohio at the time you know be good if
people believe in moral values so they
really believed in an education and
moral moral education as well and I I
think that's true but what's happened is
is that we've inculcated those beliefs
into our own beliefs without meet the
need of religion anymore without the
need of a pie in the sky watching us
because we're kind of watching each
other and so I think to go one more step
for Dennis he needs to say that it
actually needs to be a supernatural
implementation of a moral sense into
human into human cognition and I think
that that is what he believes God gave
us our morals and of course I had
counters on that which we talked about
but but ultimately he still needs that
supernatural dropping in because we can
show that societies can learn to be
better and moral just with secular law
and order
yeah I like that you brought the
founders into it because as I say all
the time I you know I go to DC every
couple months probably at this point I
go to all of the monuments and all that
and when you read these things
especially Jefferson it's like this guy
was talking about church and state and
separation the necessity for church and
state to be separate while at the same
time was sort of was basically
acknowledging some sort of higher power
how much he believed in it is I think a
little unclear yeah but that then led to
all of the values that freed us so yeah
in this long ago enough that you know
we're used to talking in language that
doesn't include God talk at that time
you know that they were there know
virtually no atheist no one was talking
about you know it's okay not to believe
in God I mean there was a famous story
about human coming to somebody's dinner
it the Enlightenment time you know you
have like Adam Smith and all these
famous now famous people and you know
Hume says well I don't know any atheist
then it's like you have a room full of
him here it's like oh my god yeah now
you and I but of course we live in LA
and California is a little more little
boys yeah so it's not a big deal but I
think more and more it's becoming more
acceptable and therefore word morals
come from well you know we talk about
the secular values enshrined in the
Constitution and the you know the law
and order of our society Western society
expanded Europe and so on and all of a
sudden you had the fastest-growing group
or the nuns the non-religious people
okay that's gonna be a third maybe a
half of the world in a few decades maybe
where they gonna get their morals well
we know where they're gonna get them
where we get them from do you think you
can live a full life while still
splitting the difference on these two
positions because I think a lot of
people are like that and I think
sometimes I even fall into that where I
can you know and I sit around so many
people that are really smart that made
compelling arguments and I can
understand their lines of thinking and I
think that sometimes I can go to
different to those different places in
different ways yeah you can live like a
full complete life without ever fully
getting to an answer that that satisfy
you know that I think so I mean like
everybody else I would prefer to have
definitive answers I have to often have
to remind myself it's
what I always say it's okay not to know
but I'm not always comfortable with it
that'd be nice to know but really by
temperament again I think I think I'm
just that scientific mindset of it's
okay to just have this question and the
more I study morals particularly when I
was writing the moral arc and now I'm
getting ready to teach this honors
course at Chapman on morality and ethics
and evolution you know so I'm rereading
all these you know debates about
abortion capital punishment we have a
textbook we're using that you know
here's the best argument for abortion
here's the best argument against
abortion and so on and it's like okay
yeah these are really good arguments on
both sides and you know it's like these
these these ethical ethics and moral
seminars you know where the professor
driving you down these like it's like a
Peter Singer kind of thing you know like
is it okay to sacrifice children you
know that are mentally [ __ ] like
what but when you actually listen to the
arguments okay it's not clear at all
which is the right moral position here
and and some reason I was just writing
about utilitarianism you know because
that this is a popular idea now it's
like wait wait wait there's some really
big flaws with you well then what we
like Conte in you know the categorical
imperative at has flaws what about
Aristotle's you know virtue ethics know
that has phlegm they all have flaws yeah
also I can think of is it's something
like this that the analogy I used in a
paper I wrote my moral manifesto that
when Kepler discovered that planets that
travel in ellipses and not circles you
know he could never no one could have
discovered something else if they're
doing their sums right and they they're
actually making accurate measurements
because that's what orbits actually
travel in I think human societies are
just many degrees of freedom more
complicated and that we're not going to
discover the answer to these moral
dilemmas but but but it's not like
post-modernism there is no moral truth
yeah maybe there's six you know the the
planets you have these six variations of
planetary orbit so humans you know have
like utilitarianism Conti and ethics and
so I think we've kind of figured out you
know a few basic principles like you
have to consider the other person's
position
you know John Rawls is veil of ignorance
like
when you Dave room and are gonna write a
law you have to do it as if you might be
you know a black woman okay all right in
that case I'm not gonna write it to
favor white males you know in fact I
better write it so that everybody gets
treated equally under this law I'm about
to write okay that that's super basic
but it really works yeah in terms of
fairness to by just asking somebody else
how would you feel if this law were
passed yeah you were the one affected
but they'll tell you right so that
principle that we have to think about
that when we're legislating you know
that's one of those again so there's
maybe in the last couple thousand years
maybe half a dozen these kind of moral
positions and you can see how they've
sorted themselves out and they're not
many new ones that come up you know and
try this try that and they you know they
either take holder they don't because
they work in terms of like improving
humanity a little bit well now I know
why I'm so close to you on the political
scale because I love that answer and
that's the spirit that I try to bring to
the show every week I would love to say
I'm pro-choice and those guys are
absolutely hundred percent wrong like
Ben Shapiro I know why he's wrong no
actually I don't I I I think I can out
argue him just slightly but at some
point here's my arguments they're good
here's his arguments they're also pretty
good alright so we just decide all right
your new book
it is out this week it is sitting right
in front of me heavens on earth the
scientific search for the afterlife
immortality and utopia well did you
figure it out is it I have the answer
got the other is there any scientific
evidence for any of those things Michael
Shermer tale no I'm sorry to say that
there's not there's actually some good
news at the end of the book but I do
address all of the different versions of
the afterlife heaven I go through the
monotheism's Judaism Christianity and
Islam of course and right off the bat
you see there's a huge body of
literature in those areas of the history
of heaven and the fact that history that
heaven has a history and now I'm a
historian of science so like cosmology
has a history the history of cosmology
how did how did we figure out how big
the universe is and all that stuff but
there there's kind of a sense of
progress like we're getting ever closer
to understanding what's actually out
there
with these history of heaven literature
there's no sense of progress at all it's
like well this group used to believe
that and then they encounter the
Egyptians and then they changed it to
this and then then they the Babylonian
captivity and that the the inca the jews
inculcated their worldview and there's
no sense like oh well there's something
out there and we're getting closer to it
not at all so that was kind of
interesting and also how they change
depending did that surprise you because
they are just hearing I mean I kind of
knew that thank you yeah no I mean that
wasn't a big thing it was just sort of
an interesting observation
I then do also have to deal with the non
monotheism's you know what it's called
the eastern wisdom traditions Buddhism
Hinduism Taoism
so I've old chapter on that I went to
Deepak Chopra Center down in Carlsbad
and got into the whole meditation and
yoga and chanting and the tea and the
incense and they're like okay Deepak
let's talk about this and so he gave me
the whole thing so I really that was
kind of my Avenue into talking about
consciousness and you know their view
the Buddhist view is there's no life and
death in the sense there's a beginning
an end like in Western culture we have
this idea of a linear linear time
there's a beginning and an end the big
bang that you know and so forth but in
in in this worldview you know the
physical universe including us we're
just visit just temporary physical
instantiation of consciousness
consciousness is pervasive it is well
okay deep box language the ground of all
being you know the ontological primitive
okay so he says these things and it
takes me you know page do you what do
you mean by the ontological perimeter
and part of the problem is that is a
Western scientist you know we use words
in a certain way that and they don't and
they use words in a different way so
we're off to just talking cross purposes
there so much of my conversations with
Deepak have been just stop tell me what
you mean by this word right because also
we have our words you know I can't read
your thoughts so anyway but the core of
the book really is scientific attempts
okay I call this the afterlife or
atheist you know these are all the the
people that are don't necessarily think
that that there's a heaven in fact
they're pretty sure there isn't anything
like a traditional heaven because
there's no evidence for that so but
interestingly in surveys I was
looking up about a third of atheists
think that there might be an afterlife
okay so they say the I don't believe in
God but there might be something what
are they talking about well you're a
Star Wars fan you know something like
the force right you know there's
something out there that you continue on
and you know and some of them do find
that kind of Deepak worldview that's
sort of Buddhist you know Buddhism has
quite a resurgence now there's a number
of books you know Bob Wright's book
Buddhism is true and so on what do you
mean it's true okay that's a that's a
big statement the truth statement okay
well okay so they think when you die you
just go back to where you were before
you were born as I open the book say
what when people say where do you think
you you go when you die summarize it the
same place I was before I was born
what are you talking about you weren't
anywhere right well did a Buddhist you
you actually are returning to where you
were because consciousness is just
always there's no beginning area and
it's just always was and is and
everywhere okay that's really hard for
us to grass so what they what the the
scientist group these communities I
delve into the Kryon assists the
transhumanists the extra pians there
against entropy good luck with that and
they're against the entropy yeah you
know there's a theory well just you know
let's they start off simple enough which
seems obvious you know diet nutrition
exercise you know be healthy and so on
in a way all of life is pushing back
against entropy this is most of what we
do is a push back against entropy you
know we have you know a house we have a
ceiling to protect us from the weather
that's fighting entropy basically nature
just wants to kill us all all the time
that's basically what it does and so
natural selection selected those that
were able to push back against it but
ultimately you can't defeat it right so
but this is you know they so you start
off it's a transhumanist sixth row and
they're all in the same category like
the soul is your genome and your
connectome the pattern of all your
information all of the stuff that your
body is made out of gets recycled about
every decade or so your skin cells blood
cells it's it's all none of the material
almost it is the original from ten years
ago even much less when you were born so
you're not the Dave Rubin you were a
decade ago I know your friends tell you
exactly
you've changed a lot so when we say well
there's a there's a unit there called
Dave Rubin who's a person and Anna self
who has a sense of self and I have a
sense of who you are that's not the
material that's the pattern of
information that's in your memories and
your genome and so on that gets the key
that keeps it going okay so their idea
the singularity people the mind
uploading so somehow you got to keep
that going alright so it starts super
basic diet and exercise just kind of
keep the body going but no one's ever
gone above the ceiling upper ceiling of
about 120 125 now so first of all one of
the myths I debunk is this idea that
people live twice as long as they used
to know more and more people are getting
up to the upper ceiling thanks to public
health measures and vaccinations and
things like that but it's not like no
one 100 years ago or 200 years ago lived
to be in their 80s or 90s
lots of people did just not as many as
do today so to get that the upper
ceiling there is blocked by a bunch of
different systems that all fall apart at
the same time around a in your 80s or so
you know just the telomeres at the end
of your chromosomes that break off every
time a cell divides they can only do
that so many times called the hayflick
number so one of the goals of the
science of aging is to somehow figure
that out well there's lots of claims
about well if you eat this supplement
every day your telomers will be better
yeah
acai berries red wine actually sleep
apparently is really good for keeping
your telomeres more in place it doesn't
allow your cells to divide more but but
that they they don't die quiet as
quickly okay again these are all
measures to just get more and more of us
up to the upper ceiling the only way to
break through there would be a complete
genetic reengineering of the genome to
stop that from happening without because
there's a there's a name for cells that
divide indefinitely
it's called cancer all right so without
turning people into cancerous blobs you
know and that's just one of you know
dozens of systems that all fall apart so
this we're not even close to the science
of like figuring that out and breaking
through but when you hear this and then
you hear about who's the Google guy
his name suddenly that's doing the
singularity yeah ray kurzweil yeah when
you hear it like he's taking like what
it likes under pills supplements a day
yeah what is it supplement 5757 today do
those he's trying to be brave that time
that's right absolutely totally ya know
so their program okay so every aging
expert I've talked to they have world's
leading this is all [ __ ] it's not
gonna happen
not without program but you'd have to so
maybe a crisper a future CRISPR
technology where you actually reprogram
the genome to stop the telomeres for
breaking off so frequently in the cell
then devote dying without creating
cancer okay that's a huge problem but
that's just one of many
you know Aubrey de Grey any documentary
you've ever seen on aging and longevity
and immortality you've seen him he's got
long red hair a long but through Scylla
a beard he loves beer he has he's
British that means bridge because it's a
great British accent and you know the
first person to live a thousand years is
alive today and you know he's got a
whole program sends Sen s this is
basically these seven things you got to
do to reprogram your cells okay so you
can you could read about it come up it's
great stuff but open any likes beer and
beers on the lit list so that's good but
ultimately know that none of this is
going to work now the Kurzweil is
program is it goes beyond that okay even
if we don't succeed you can you can have
yourself chronically frozen and maybe a
thousand years from now okay well first
of all you're being frozen on the worst
day of your life the day you're died the
state treats cryonics is a form of
burial right so you can't like prep
yourself with the antifreeze stuff or
all that because they'll kill you and
then that would be murder so you
actually have to just let her let things
take their course and you're dead then
the team rushes in and packed you a nice
and ships you off to Alcor one of these
places and they pump you full of this
antifreeze stuff to try to prevent the
freezing from destroying your cells
anyway it doesn't work because a like a
human brain is it's huge compared to an
embryo so you can freeze an embryo bring
it back IVF it works not brains they're
too big and so so far everybody frozen
today they're never being brought back
it's not going to happen
Disney frozen or nothing no no that was
that's just not even true the day he
died was the day
that I think it was Alcor one of them
opened their doors and there was the two
complaining press releases Ted Williams
though is apparently his head is frozen
that Alcoa parently that is true yeah
and the first person ever frozen was a
Glendale college psychology professor
where I went as a student no he was
already dead and frozen by the time I
got there but I thought well that's a
weird thing yeah now so here's the other
problem with Kurzweil this idea okay so
in the meantime if we could copy your
connectome again this it's it's you are
represented by your memories yeah all
your pattern of information in there put
it in a computer just scan every
synaptic connection and put it in a
giant computer okay so first of all
we're not even remotely close to having
a big enough computer dolt even one
brain much less a hundred brains of the
elite or everybody's brain but even so
let's say Moore's law you know carry it
out a hundred years from now the problem
here is the problem of identity who are
you so let's say we we scan your brain
and put it in the computer
at what age you know when you're 29
they're 30 you know because that's
supposedly the ideal age cuz that's when
Jesus died right because in Christianity
there's a debate about when you wake up
in heaven with Jesus there and so on
who's there is are you physically there
you know some of them say yeah you're
physically there how old yeah well okay
thirty thirty okay nobody wants to get
to heaven as the 95 I guess not but but
if you think about that well then what
about all the memories I've had since I
was thirty because I've had 33 of them
33 years of memories that they'd be lost
I that would be tragic and but but but
so Kay no you can have the memories of
your total life yeah but the memories
now I'm 63 now the memories of when I
was 40 now are very different from the
memories when I was 40 when that was
happening yeah whatever it was my
interpretation of that now is different
everything is different so even scanning
every memory isn't really capturing you
as hard a problem that would be and and
then there's also the point of view
problem like when you go to sleep
tonight you wake up tomorrow morning
you're a little groggy but consciousness
comes back and you're looking at the
world through your eyes so it called
this the point of view self instead of
the memory self so the point of view
self is there's a continuity of
consciousness and and perspective now
you go under general anesthesia you wake
up a little
groggy or five hours later and it comes
back if you are copied and put in a
computer and they turn it on like Johnny
Depp and transcendence he's in the
computer looking out through the little
camera you know and there's his
girlfriend with the guy who what yeah
you're doing what and yeah no no that's
not gonna happen
because your point of view isn't going
to transfer from your body into the
computer because let's say we did this
to a fancy fMRI brain scanner and we did
this while you're standing there you
just like we slide you in scan your
brain we get every single synaptic
connection put it in the computer turn
it on and you're still standing there
next to the Machine you all of a sudden
don't go into there your point of view
you're still standing there going hey no
I'm Dave over here and then the
computers going no I'm Dave it's just a
copy right and no twin ever looks at
their sibling and go well there I am
yeah no no no not now so the Kurzweil is
of the world will say yes there's there
could be 10 Dave Reubens but each of
them thinks they're the real day of
Reuben but of course the moment you
diverge and have different life
experiences you just go left and the
other one goes right out of the room and
all of a sudden life it becomes
different you're gonna have different
memories and different connections and
so who's the real you ok so it's really
a problem of philosophy these guys have
you're not gonna wake up in the computer
it's just a copy so where are you yeah
and religions kind of have the same
problem you know you're dead in the
grave and what Jesus takes you up there
well what's going up there well the soul
what does that mean pattern information
at what age they have the same set of
logical problems because it for Jew for
Jews in particular the body is still in
the grave and many Christian sects say
you know your body is not resurrected
it's just your soul the body says yeah
but the your memories are in there in
the grave
no no they get taken up there how does
this happen you know God works in
mysterious ok poom man I just watched I
just watch the matrix for like the
thousandth time there's a lot of matrix
ways I can go with this but I'll try to
try to keep it a little more narrow for
this so is there an inherent problem
discussing all this that you're trying
to look at something through a
scientific lens that the people who are
the believers simply don't look through
that lens so you're never gonna get to
uh I guess this is the struggle of the
skeptic all times right
it's hard to get to somebody to break
through to somebody that is going off a
different set of premises to start yes
okay that's it that is a problem right
so but my book is a work of science and
the primary focus is you know not not
only that I'm skeptical of religious
versions of the afterlife but all these
scientific attempts they're not going to
succeed therefore what we do now is all
the more important our lives our loves
our connections and all that so I end
with a you know a really uplifting
chapter but ultimately yes I do think in
the chapter on Deepak I talk about this
problem of language you know the seeing
the world through a scientific
perspective is very it's not in the
majority position most people are
duelists they're Paul bloom calls them
calls us natural-born duelists and in
his lab with children he shows that like
if it'll two-year-old you know here's a
mouse and it gets munched by the
alligator now the mouse is dead you know
what where is the mouse oh the mouse is
off in this other place and he misses
his mommy and he's hungry and from a
very early age we have this sense that
something continues on mm-hmm
so I actually opened the book by talking
about this problem of imagine you're
dead you know most people say well I see
my body in the casket and all my friends
and family are there and hopefully
they're mourning but of course you
wouldn't see anything because you know
to be conscious of anything you have to
be alive and so you know imagine you
can't imagine anything it's it's a it's
like imagine there's no universe not not
just no planets stars and galaxies no
space-time no light nothing you can't
you can't actually imagine that in the
in so here we we bump up against the
epistemological wall and the language
wall like Vic and Stein talked about
this you know these words we use they
get reified into things even the word
nothing it's no thing it's a thing that
doesn't exist
well well when you're dead it's not like
you're going to this place called
nothing no you see all of a sudden we
just hit this word like if there's no
universe there's nothing as if nothing
is a thing it's not even that
so the that you ended this book on a
positive note I guess by arguing that
there's no scientific basis for an
afterlife or a utopia or whatever else
you're really putting the onus I think
this is what you
saying sort of you're putting the onus
on us right this moment absolutely yeah
which is scary for a lot of people well
I think it's it should be uplifting it's
like because instead of thinking well
either I don't matter or none of this
really matters I'm just waiting for the
next stage or the next play the next act
in the play and this proscenium drama
we're in here it's just a temporary
thing you're gonna miss out on something
now look I don't know that there's no
afterlife nobody does for sure
so whether there's an afterlife or not
this is the life we live in right here
right now I call this alvey's error so
in Annie Hall is a flashback scene where
you know Woody Allen plays Alvy Singer
yeah and he's eight years old or
whatever and he won't do his homework
and his mother takes him the
psychiatrist aldi why I want you do your
homework the universe is expanding the
universe is expanding yeah the universe
is expanding and eventually it's all
gonna blow up so none of this matters
and his mother yells at him we live in
Brooklyn Brooklyn's not expanding you
got to do your homework well that's kind
of my message you know we live in
Brooklyn
we don't live 15 billion years from now
the heat death in the universe nothing
matters we don't live in heaven with
Jesus now none of that actually matters
now yeah what matters is now and the
people you're in the room with is
society you live in the people you
engage with and so all of those things
matter more than ever once you think
about it and put them in big perspective
whatever your beliefs are in the
afterlife when you were around all these
different groups of people whether they
were Jewish or Christian or Hindu or
Buddhist or whatever it is even if none
of it could be proved in one way or
another and none of the science was
there backing up anything they said did
you sense that any group of them had a
better handle on this I think Jews I
think Jews are a little more realistic
about I mean the original idea of the
afterlife for Jews was it was nothing
it's like you just we don't go anywhere
now modern Jews that they do believe in
an afterlife nothing quite as extreme
like Christians have a whole elaborate
idea of what it's going to be like and
the Left Behind and all that stuff I
think Jews are more realistic
particularly their focus on rituals now
family community taking care of one
another
and so the Christian sects that do
I admire more in respect more though the
Christian groups that want to help the
poor now man the soup kitchens care
about people that are suffering as
opposed to those that are fanatically
obsessed with you know say they
afterlife or evangelizing converting
people there is this kind of split in
Christianity on you know that it's kind
of a political split you know liberal
Christians tend to be more like our duty
is now and Jesus wants us to help poor
people and you know and so there for
women's rights and you know the rights
of minorities and so on and the others
that tend to be more conservative
conservative Christian says sort of that
started starting the 80s with the moral
majority we're not worried about those
people our job is to get our guy into
into the white house and then we can
influence the the elections and
legislation with our beliefs yeah he was
big on the rich yeah wait when did that
happen when did Jesus become a
conservative anyway so I think you asked
you know what if I think those the idea
of that the here and now and taking care
of people making a world a better place
that's where it's at yeah the utopia one
is interesting to me because first off
did you get a sense that across the
board when people say utopia they mean
the same thing what do they mean by
utopia do they mean just this endless
place of pleasures and ocular one yeah
what do they actually mean by utopia
well people mean different things by it
but but you know I cover that from the
commune's 19th century American communes
which are relatively harmless you know
people think people weren't murdered
they didn't commit mass suicide they had
a lot of free sex so you know how bad
could it be not very successful they
didn't last long to the kind of utopian
cults like the Heaven's Gate or the
Jonestown where they that does get a
little riskier like like we're gonna
sacrifice ourselves and go to the other
side where it's even better I mean
Jones's final speech he's talking about
this you know sort of utopian communist
state that we're all going to in this
next world but really community of Marx
if you look at Marxism there's a book
about this on comparisons of
Christianity and Marxism you know there
was a glorious paradisaical state before
the fall and that's when there was no
property no private property everybody
had an equal share everybody
did their equal share of work and then
there was the fall you know like the
following was that he well when right
well they think of this you know they in
Paleolithic times prehistoric
prehistoric they you know they they had
this idea this is the way it was like
now it's true hunter-gatherers are more
egalitarian than we are but but they're
far from any kind of idealistic
communist state any case that's what
they always had a certain set problems
but they certainly did much worse you
know more violence more tribalism more
rape and pillage in and say yeah of
course but this is Marxist idea and then
the fall which private property
capitalism comes on ruins everything and
then we have our second coming you know
capitalism will eventually collapse on
its own but we can kind of help it along
you know and and then when it collapses
communism will return you know so it's a
very prelapsarian and then the fall and
then the return to the Golden Age it's a
it's an old idea you know that comes up
often and it's we have a big enough
brain to imagine what life could be like
and it could be better than now yes
absolutely
so therefore we should aim for this you
know perfect state you know and so I
talk about why does this fail they
always fail and the problem is is this
human nature is too variable there's too
many different interests and talents and
skills and whatever that there is the
question what's the right Society there
is no answer because there isn't one
right Society so the flaw is us right I
mean this is you're talking about a lot
lately we can't make a perfect system
because we are not perfect right and and
even you even saying it that way I would
say it we're just so variable there's
multiple well I like Sam's metaphor
multiple Peaks on the moral landscape
there isn't one right answer there's
multiple answers now there's a bunch of
wrong answers and some Peaks are higher
than others yeah so but but like say
what's the right democracy you know
should we have an electoral college or
not should we have a progressive tax
regressive tax or flat tax I'm not sure
there's a right answer to those you
might say well for us this is what we
want to do because this is what we like
it's like the you know the private
community that says no doors can be
painted red in this neighborhood period
and you can't paint your house pink
either you know you know these
Association rules
okay but this association over here you
know there's sort of the hippie
community you want you can paint your
door any color you want and in fact the
more colors the better okay so in a free
market you just let this kind of happen
so the problem with a top-down by Fiat
these are the rules because this is the
right way to live that will always fail
because there is no right way to live
so it's interesting I mean your book is
about belief and science of that but
you're making great arguments really
again for things that I know you believe
in otherwise like the individual
animated state power and the control and
you owning your life and being proud
well I think there's I think there's
evidence and reason for those positions
as being correct but you know that we
are the individual is the fundamental
unit of a political nature because it's
the individual who can suffer it's the
individual brain that experiences pain
and suffering not the collective you
know races don't vote individual members
of a race vote you know so again we have
to get out of this problem we've talked
about identity politics I don't want to
be a a white guy that's how you treat me
I'm just an Indian rear Dave Reuben
we're different the individual is what
counts and and we know from experiments
over say the last three or four
centuries in governance some work better
than others now again it could be that
you know a progressive tax is slightly
better than a regressive tax okay you
can debate that but a totalitarian state
is is objectively measurably worse than
a democratic state you only have to ask
yourself would you rather live in North
Korea or South Korea would you rather
have lived in West Germany or East
Germany yeah and so on you just pick
these that these aren't controlled
experiments they're natural experiments
that happen anyway everything then study
them after that that's science right
that's what scientists do most of
science is not done with controlled
experiments it's done with the
comparative method most social science
what has already happened okay so these
these states have these gun control laws
these have these different gun control
laws this comparison compare them now
it's messy you know you get in these
correlational studies that are very
complicated but still it's a method that
can get us there I think yeah it's sort
of like well
do you rather live in Venezuela right
now or the United States right I know
I'll see every now and again that the
official socialist Twitter handle that's
verified which I always think is well
there was such a thing oh yeah you know
the the Socialist Party of America are
saying it it's very okay and of course
they're using all the tools of
capitalism to promote the very same
things that okay fine but they oh you
know people always so we'll look at that
as well as say well no it's just never
done right their argument is it was just
never done right yeah which perhaps says
there's something wrong with you yeah
and I see some of that in the kind of
far extreme libertarians it's sort of
anarcho-capitalists you know well we
don't really need government yeah well
what about all these oh that's just not
capitalism done right okay wait a minute
guys now we've had you know two
centuries here of the experiment in
America which is relatively free and
still you see why some you know steering
from the the government is good some
rules people will cheat if you don't
have rules just look at sports yeah and
I'm amazed they may cheat either way but
that doesn't mean there's right that's
right we need rules so you know again
just don't go don't go to extremes are
almost always a problem and anyway so
the chapters on utopia is in dystopias
are addressing the claims about what we
can create heaven on earth know again
like when they like the Ray Kurzweil say
to me don't you want to live to be a
thousand years Shermer listen just get
me into ninety yes I don't have cancer
give me to a hundred where I don't have
Alzheimer's I don't even know who I am
110 where I'm not gonna morphine drip in
a bed just you know just a little bit
yeah and again you know it's like let's
just try to lower the crime rates in
Chicago this year this is just one thing
you know like we know that you know if
you park a squad car at the corner of
Pico and Sepulveda you know the crime
rate will go down right there okay just
one little bit now to you know to the
average you know college student that's
not sexy I want I want to aim for a
thousand years from now gonna have the
perfect society right you mean like the
Third Reich you mean that kind of you
know right word where it just never gets
it I guess is the inherent problem with
that though that when Michael Shermer is
90 and let's say they've done enough
things and you've tweaked it right so
that you don't have Alzheimer's in your
bodies basically okay but you know
you're getting
and suddenly you are gonna keep wanting
to extend that course absolutely
you know serve a show that you know that
most people will say how long would you
like to live it's almost always right
around the average life the lifespan
that we have now you know about 80 85 90
seems about right now if you had asked
them 50 years ago Wow I'd be happy if I
make it to 65 and get my retirement you
know so but but this is easily refuted
if you were now 82 and we said would you
like to do tomorrow's the day no no I
need another week okay then the week is
that would you like another month I'll
take another month you know now I'm not
talking about you're on a morphine drip
in a bed and you're out of it I'm
talking about just leading a normal
healthy life in your conscious and aware
and sharp and you know would you like
another year yeah yeah I'll take another
year yeah of course people would say
that once you get there now people are
thinking on me they're gonna be on in a
bed on a morphine drip or they're
thinking oh this is bad for society
there'll be too many people over a
population of people lived 150 years
that they need to die you know like it's
a Soylent Green thing like we're gonna
turn them into food and you know it's
never them of course that's gonna do
this it's always you know it's the same
thing with people you know
overpopulation well we need to get those
people are you gonna handle on birth
control and they can't have babies you
mean those people over there you know
the other ones that are not like us you
know okay no no good it's so interesting
this reminds me of my grandma's cousin
so I guess it's my she's my first cousin
twice removed
I suppose a barber she's 87 years old I
think maybe 88 lives in Manhattan
Manhattan born and bred her entire life
basically in Manhattan which is a really
unique type of thing she's a piano
teacher and I was talking to her about
life meaning a life all this stuff about
a year ago and she said I just have so
much more to do but I just thought what
a great what a great thing for 87 who's
who's happy and laughs and I don't have
you know drinks with her and she's
standing on and vibrate and all of that
but I thought that's really something I
still have so much more to do
right when most people are kind of
packing it up yeah or feeling around
well the research on that shows that
does does make a difference you know
again not to live 200 wherever just just
and back to the here and now just to
live a higher-quality more richer life
which we have the availability to do so
now not for a thousand years from now
just for tomorrow and next week next
year and so on and those kinds of things
being actively involved working out
exercising everyday eating Whole Foods I
mean even even the diet stuff is you
know that's really hard to get you know
we know now at least a few things sugar
and you know starches processed
carbohydrates you know the fast foods
that stuff's not so good you know now it
turns out meat and eggs are back in hey
whole milk I can drink whole milk on my
cereal I told you when you got here I'm
starting this Paleo diet oh yes yes
ok great I'm doing it's a lot of butter
and coconut oh yeah yeah asically I
think that my temperaments been pretty
good yeah so far you're not falling
apart at all right but those are the
things you're saying basically take
control of the things you can in your
life to maximize yes and in like having
lots of choices making decisions like
old-people in what I call the sort of
homes lost my train of thought there but
you know these nursing homes yeah the
more the nurses do for them the worse it
is for the page they really need to be
actively involved and get out and move
in these to get the blood flowing and
decision making and so on any other
Studies on you know the nuns that kept
Diaries their whole life you know they
had lower rates of Alzheimer's there's a
few studies that show being act mentally
active may help attenuate the plaques
and tangles that are associated with
Alzheimer's that research is a little
complicated and it's not as good as I
would like it you know if I just played
chess or did soduku puzzles everyday I
won't get I was like unfortunately we
can't really say that but right but I
think we can say Twitter is destroying
yes that's probably Twitter Alzheimer's
are both gonna yes that may be one of
those correlations well listen Trevor I
think we should well I have a feeling
we're gonna do this you know many times
over the course of many years they come
back with bonus round right certainly we
should do it when you're about 90 yes I
see where I'm at and then we'll go does
he want a little more time here I'll
take two more Ruben shows when I'm 100
Liz it's always an absolute pleasure
you're pretty much the perfect guest and
I want to get more people to our
quadrant
of the political thing because I think
you've proven here really perhaps proven
but maybe in a more broad sense you've
illustrated that it's not just about
that political part there's something
else right about how to live or
something yeah that puts us maybe in
that reliant that we're always working
on and that's really very cool well what
you're doing just talking to people
that's that's where it starts what else
can we do but talk and then act what
else can we do by doctor and act all
right heavens on earth we're gonna link
to it right down below and you can
follow Michael on the Twitter machine
which is not good cognitive health or
your sanity but if you want to go for it
it's at Michael Shermer
[Music]
you